alors ça vient de paraître chez boréal
l'auteur frédéric lacroix le titre
pourquoi la loi 101 est un échec
vous voyez un castor qui gruge la statue
de camille laurin camille laurens qui a
évidemment il est l'auteur et le père de
la loi 101 frédéric lacroix est avec
nous bonsoir monsieur lacroix beaufort
le miroir je vais présenter puis là je
n'aurai pas les gens du chiffre parce
qu'on parle de langue ça ça rebute
beaucoup les j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de
chutes
vous même vous le savez vous avez
analyser tout ça mais langue maternelle
alors bon ça on le sait un déclin du
français et jusqu'à on a des chiffres
correspondent 2016 on ne relève dans
quelques mois le nouveau recensement
mais ça baise grand montréal sa baisse
donc sa baisse et en dessous de la barre
des 80 quand on regarde la langue parlée
à la maison
autre indicateur de 82,8 on est à 80
cadres landaise montréal est à 68,1
monsieur lacroix pourquoi vous êtes si
dur dans votre analyse dans votre
conclusion
pourquoi vous dites la loi 101 est un et
chania quand même tous les enfants de
l'immigration qui vont à l'école
française depuis cette loi là non pour
pour conclure que la loi serait un échec
pour se reporter aux objectifs que viser
la loi se fait d'objectif en détail dans
le livre blanc que camille laurin a
déposé un peu avant la loi l'objectif
numéro 1 la loi c'était d'arrêter
l'érosion c'était déjà prévu pro
démocratique des francophones au québec
puis pour faire ce qu'ils voulaient
faire c'est diriger le la discussion les
geeks des d'allophones majoritairement
vers le français donc c'était deux
objets c'est ce que visait la loi fillon
se reportent aujourd'hui aux derniers
ont données du dernier recensement de
2000 da l on se rend compte que
l'érosion qui était annoncé du poids des
francophones elles elles se déroulent
depuis 15 ans on assiste à ça puis les
solutions linguistiques des allophones
qui ont été rehaussés donc la loi est
venu
améliorer le fait français mais pas
suffisamment pour diriger ses fonctions
le 2
d'accord mais faut quand même établir
que sans la doit sans les choses
auraient été bien pires
du point de vue du français au québec
tout à fait la loi était inutile loin de
là je suis tellement en train de cuire
qu' elle n'est pas suffisante pour et
une sécurité culturelle pour les
francophones au québec
et vous vous dites que pour aider comme
remède il faudrait s'attaquer au cégep
et à l'enseignement supérieur
parce que vous dites que la très
preneurs en un tableau le l'état
francophone inscrits au cégep en anglais
de 2002 s'est pas assez de 22,4 on va le
voir dans une seconde à 28,2 donc à plus
de francophones qui vont étudier au
cégep en anglais pour devenir bilingues
et c est pourquoi l'autre tableau est la
cause de ce qu'on vient dire c'est que
on demande beaucoup l'aider une
compétence en anglais 62,9 à montréal 40
% dans l'ensemble du québec
vous vous dites c'est ça qu'il faut
freiner ouais moi je pense qu'il faut
freiner l'apprentissage de l'anglais
loin de là ce que je dis c'est que la
page de l'anglais chez les francophones
aujourd'hui il est très très attendu
puis chez les francophones qui font au
second bail
la plupart des gens il est donc ne vont
plus au collégial en anglais pour
apprendre l'anglais mais le choisissent
parce que c'est le système est un prix
supérieur maintenant donc c'est une
question de valeurs que je parle et
parle déjà anglais donc su sélectionner
auquel les anglais ont déjà déjà qu'ils
sont très très très doux dingues qui
vont là parce que c'est l'action là ont
un prestige souvent supérieurs à ceux
des 900 pas la date à date par le jazz
c'est le cjev le plus primé à montréal
et de loin donc les ja veulent inscrire
mes amis c'est quand même assez large
même du pq ya pas si longtemps du parti
libéral et de la caq maintenant de ne
pas inclure les cegep totalement
assujettir les cégeps à la loi 101
c'était de dire oui peut-être qu'ils
parlent anglais à l'entrée mais ils
voient pas ils vont parler écrire
l'anglais beaucoup mieux à la sortie
d'un cégep anglophone bas peut-être mais
moi je peux soit je suis pas sûr que le
niveau d'anglais qui l'ont à l'entrée
sous est déficient donc je pense que
l'anglais que par les zones francophones
surtout ceux qui l'ont séparé glissons
sur des finissants de l'école privée des
programmes particuliers ils ont un
excellent niveau d'anglais
donc je pense que notre fer de
l'améliorer encore d'accord dans votre
esprit alors que faudrait-il faire
maintenant pour redresser les choses il
faudrait taper de revenir le plus
possible la loi 101 original donc il
faudrait que un des axes importants
c'est de faire du français la langue de
l'état québécois
actuellement l'état québécois est devenu
un état bilingue dans l'excès il offre
la loi le choix la langue d'intégration
à tous unigrains aussi on a su on a
suivi le général
donc on est ok la politique des lois
dont la loi sur les langues officielles
pour cet aspect là si moi je pense que
l'éducation c'est vraiment le nerf de la
guerre parce que quand on a conçu la loi
101 originalement le diplôme d'études
secondaires étaient le diplôme le plus
remis au québec
donc les études collégiales était encore
seulement le fait d'une minorité qui
maintenant aujourd'hui les études
collégiales sont rendus au même niveau
que le nombre de mandats à deux ils se
remettent au québec donc l'amélioration
de la diplomation fait que le post
secondaires dont j'ai plus d'une heure
joue un rôle de plus en plus important
dans la formation
et comment aussi déjà cet été les
graciés par le premier mené ce qu' ils
ne vont pas imposer la loi 101 aussi
complètement ils vont limiter l'accès à
certains francophones en jouant sur les
quotas etc sur le non est ce que dablé
vous dites ça va être cosmétiques ça ne
sera pas suffisant pour moi c'est
vraiment le fun minimal à atteindre pour
que le projet de loi soit vraiment
portable
je pense qu il ya les mesures sont
importantes mais aussi le signal que le
projet doivent envoyer ce signal aux
doit être fort l effet que le français
revient au centre du jeu que le français
revient au devient la langue de
référence au québec
donc ça prend une mesure symbolique fort
donc je fais pas on le projet de loi est
pas un public encore de jeu fait pour
qu'elle soit cette mesure mais c'est
peut être qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
avec vous toutes vos conclusions
monsieur lacroix on peut pas vous
reprocher ne pas avoir potassé dans les
chiffres parce que votre livre
il ya beaucoup de chefs ya beaucoup de
tableaux et c'est assez clair c'est une
lecture intéressant parce que le débat
qu'on va rouvrir au québec ça c'est sûr
avec la croix merci beaucoup nous avons
pas merci merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit